let's prove it okay so this is the first
this is the fundamental login right if
you've got numbers like let's go I
choose you choose these two if I'm
adding two logs okay
what I'm suggesting is you take these
two numbers before the eight and you
multiply them so this is what I want to
prove okay you see that if I add these
two logs I'm gonna multiply these two
numbers together okay how do I prove it
oh do I prove it what I'm gonna do is
I'm gonna take these two pieces on the
left-hand side right
let's take this guy let's call him a nut
but let's give my name let's call him M
and at the same time I'm gonna take this
guy and also give him a name there you
go okay now the reason why I'm doing
this is what's you give something a name
this is what I was looking at just this
morning before all of you arrived once
you give something a name you can work
with it this is the strategy of algebra
or whatever again if you have a name for
it you can do some maths with it right
okay so by definition if I'm writing
this log equation just like this one how
can i rewrite it as an exponential
someone help me out
notice the bases right the base is here
two are the same as the base over here
okay so I can write the statement a ^
now where does the time go
the time is over here which really
should belong in the index right do you
see that so I'm gonna put time up there
we're used to it and that's equal to
your last number does that make sense
what can I write over here what's a
corresponding equation that fits this
patent over here good I've got the same
machine where's the same rate but I grow
for a different amount of time should be
great for different by the time you'll
have a different final size that makes
sense okay good
now knowing your index fours right I can
take these two guys and I can multiply
them right I can say a times M a to
power of n times n power n that
x1 do you agree with that like I've just
substituted them directly okay so with
your index laws what's that left-hand
side can become what happens when you
multiply numbers with the same base you
add their indices right you add their a
Z so this is a to the power of M plus M
right and the right hand side haven't
changed okay now that is a new
exponential equation right so just like
I turn these log equations into
Exponential's
I can turn this exponential into a log
log base what what's the base again yeah
this base here becomes this base here
right so the basis stay the same I
always start by writing the most like
that okay what's my final size what
comes next
how people they end up heads up ex-wife
right that's usually where I end X Y and
what's left is just the last of my know
video and plus n which is the time right
and Plus hold on a second I don't omit n
R I define them up here right that's in
and that's in so I can just substitute
them back and this proves the more that
I was trying to establish from the
beginning
okay so I've got my 1 2 3 4 5 6 which
land are you interested in it's like
here we go yeah this is what I'm trying
to prove yep
yes that's right yes that one yes yes
sure so here all I've done is upstair
look remember I just pedal back but you
all understand what's going on
what did I do in this step what was this
step about all I did in this step was
just give names right I haven't changed
to exponential just yet okay
I said he's an object let me give it a
name here's another object let me give
it a name okay
now how do I go from this step to this
that was when I changed it into an
exponential right so this is like taking
my coin and you're looking at heads
excuse me and now looking at tails just
the same object then I just turn it
around okay and I did it twice
okay now once I get to this step I
combine these two because why not like
if I know what one number is I know the
other one is then multiplying and one by
the other these are the same thing right
that's X those are both X and those are
both wide okay so I just made up this
equation and I knew to make it up
because remember I said this is the
reverse of this right so that's why my
mind went there I knew that this law is
just like this law in Reverse okay in
fact if any of you are struggling with
your log rules you just need to come
back to your index laws that's where
they really belong and that's where they
all come from okay so that's how I got
this line just by taking these two it
multiplied them okay